alors attention aux démarrons des
bahamas celle-ci d'accord c'est assez
facile
allez pour vos brigitte attention vous
avez vu vous avez le droit de m'aider il
va bien j'aurai attendu c'est le père
qui prend les choses en main
[Rires]
[Applaudissements]
brigitte est ce que quand même bien
qu'elle ait calé cette position alors
puisque je pense que ça doit être à 1,69
le 69 c'est le bon numéro
allez la deuxième la deuxième est resté
allongé est allongé dans son salon
attention la deuxième
la deuxième la deuxième il va s'occuper
de tout ça qui s'émousse alors attention
mais à 6 attention même pas comment
[Musique]
c'est pas ça pour l'instant pas ici
c'est beau la belle volée
[Rires]
ils ont essayé de faire le mouton
mauricie